♪♪
-Let's get to the news.
President Biden on Friday
ordered air strikes
against Syria.
Well, that certainly
didn't take long.
It's like going
to a Chumbawamba concert,
and they open with
"Tubthumping."
I mean, we knew it was coming.
We just didn't know
it would be right away.
According to a new poll
taken at CPAC,
68% of attendees
want former President Trump
to run again in 2024.
Only 68%?
At CPAC?
It's like if you went
to a Phish concert
and weed was polling at 68%.
[ Laughter ]
A giant golden replica
of former President Trump
was displayed over the weekend
at the Conservative Political
Action Conference in Florida.
This news first reported
in Exodus 32:4.
[ Laughter ]
President Biden
is facing criticism
after declining
to directly sanction
Saudi Arabia's
Crown Prince Mohammed bin Salman
for ordering the death
of journalist Jamal Khashoggi.
Okay. If having
a journalist murdered
doesn't count as malarkey,
what does?
Biden's like one of those
cool parents who says --
[ As Biden ]
If you kids have
to kill someone,
I'd rather you do it
in the house.
[ Laughter ]
After he was publicly accused
of sexual harassment
by two former aides,
New York Governor Andrew Cuomo
yesterday issued an apology,
even though one aide made
her accusation from a hospital,
so, to him, it doesn't count.
[ Laughter ]
In his statement addressing
accusations of sexual harassment
from aides,
governor Cuomo
said he was "being playful."
You know how he's
always joking around, right?
Look at that face.
What a prankster.
[ Laughter ]
Vice President Kamala Harris
had a call
with the International
Space Station last week.
Even that call
had a better connection
than most calls
at the Golden Globes.
[ Laughter ]
The 78th Golden Globe Awards
were held last night,
after being delayed
for nearly two months
by the coronavirus pandemic.
Though, you didn't have to wait
the whole two months
in front of your computer,
Al Pacino.
[ Laughter ]
New York City's
Peter Luger Steak House
has partnered
with Madame Tussauds Museum
to fill empty seats
in its dining room
with wax statues of celebrities,
in case you're wondering
where Mike Pence
has been hiding.
[ Laughter ]
And finally, a cat in California
was recently reunited
with her family
after she went missing
15 years ago, as a kitten.
Or -- and hear me out --
cats look alike.
[ Laughter ]
Don't get me wrong.
It's a miracle for your family.
It's not the same cat.
♪♪
Former President Trump
and former First Lady
Melania Trump
reportedly received
the coronavirus vaccine
at the White House in January.
I guess that's alright.
I mean,
he has preexisting conditions
and she works in elder care.
[ Laughter ]
That's right,
Trump and Melania received
the coronavirus vaccine
in January,
but this is weird --
January of 2018.
So...
[ Laughter ]
President Miden --
President Biden -- excuse me --
met virtually
with Mexican President Obrador
yesterday
to discuss immigration;
trade; the pandemic;
and, because it's impossible
to not have an opinion on it,
"Wandavision."
Vice President Kamala Harris
today swore in
Dr. Miguel Cardona
as Education secretary
and he's already outperforming
Betsy DeVos.
Raise your right hand.
Wow!
First try!
[ Laughter ]
This guy's good!
New York Governor Andrew Cuomo's
administration
announced yesterday
that it has hired
a prominent defense attorney,
as Cuomo faces investigations
into sexual harassment
and coronavirus
nursing home deaths.
And, in a sign of just how badly
things are going for Cuomo,
yeah, it's him.
[ Laughter ]
[ As Giuliani ]
Happy to serve!
In a new episode
of their podcast,
former President Barack Obama
sings with Bruce Springsteen.
Unfortunately, this country
has determined that you cannot
impeach a president
after they leave office.
Students
at the University of Texas
have filed a petition to change
their alma mater song,
titled "The Eyes of Texas,"
because it has racist origins.
And just wait until they find
out about the origins of Texas.
[ Laughter ]
It was announced yesterday
that the first space hotel
will begin construction in 2025
and will include features
such as restaurants, a health
spa, and a movie theater.
And, if the movie's sold out,
you could always
look at the Earth
from outer space!
[ Laughter ]
What do you think, kids?
You want to watch Vin Diesel
struggle through some dialogue,
or do you want
to look at the Earth
from outer space?!
[ Laughter ]
That's right, they're building
the first space hotel in 2025.
Finally, a hotel where
a room service Caesar salad
should be $27.
[ Laughter ]
They don't have anchovies
in space.
[ Laughter ]
And, finally, actor Seth Rogen
yesterday announced the launch
of his new cannabis brand,
called Houseplant,
and it must be good, because he
announced it again today.
[ Laughter ]
After Texas Governor Greg Abbott
announced yesterday
that he was lifting
coronavirus restrictions,
California Governor Gavin Newsom
tweeted, "Absolutely reckless."
But I don't think it helped
that he tweeted it
from The French Laundry.
White House Press Secretary
Jen Psaki said yesterday
that states will now receive
2.8 million doses
of the newly approved
Johnson & Johnson vaccine,
which is great,
but the question was
about air strikes in Syria.
President Biden said yesterday
that his goal
is that every teacher
can receive
the first dose
of the coronavirus vaccine
by the end of March.
Said teachers, "May receive."
[ Laughter ]
Twitter announced
a new system yesterday
to curb disinformation
about coronavirus vaccines
on its platform.
Any tweets about vaccines
will contain a flag
to let you know
if the person tweeting it
was a child star in the '80s.
Former Trump White House
Press Secretary Kayleigh McEnany
joined Fox News yesterday
as an on-air commentator,
so it's kind of like
her old job,
except, now, she'll be on Fox
a little less.
Treasury Secretary Janet Yellen
said recently
that Senator Elizabeth Warren's
proposed tax on millionaires
could be,
"too messy to implement,"
which was then seconded by the
Senator from East Virginia,
Guy Realperson.
Wait a minute!
[ Laughter ]
There's no
Senator Guy Realperson!
And I'm pretty sure
there's no East Virginia.
Check it, Shoemaker.
According to a new poll,
almost 30% of voters
would entertain the idea
of splitting the country
into smaller regions --
specifically, two.
[ Laughter ]
Following recent power outages
amid a winter storm,
some Texans
were reportedly asked
to treat missed days of work
as vacation days,
while others didn't have
to be asked.
According to a new report,
people 75 years or older
are the second most vulnerable
to fraud attacks.
I would say
call your congressmen
to do something about it,
but they're on the line
with the reverse mortgage
company right now.
"Don't sell me
down the river, Quigley."
[ Laughter ]
A small porcelain bowl
that was purchased
at a Connecticut yard sale
for $35
was recently revealed to be
a rare 15th-century
Chinese artifact
worth up to $500,000.
Said the Connecticut homeowner,
"Which is...
a lot?"
[ Laughter ]
And, finally, a man
in California is facing a fine
after he allegedly
used a mannequin
for at least a year and a half
to drive in the carpool lane.
He probably
could have got out of it,
but his lawyer
didn't say a word.
[ Laughter ]
Still beats Rudy!
♪♪
New York Governor Andrew Cuomo
held his first
press conference yesterday
since three women
came forward last week
to accuse him
of sexual harassment
and it didn't go great.
[ Laughter ]
Governor Andrew Cuomo
said yesterday
that he feels embarrassed
about the multiple allegations
of sexual harassment against him
and added that kissing is his,
"usual and customary
way of greeting."
I'm not sure
it's a great defense,
if you're being accused
of bad behavior, to say, "Hey,
that bad behavior is
how I say hello."
Also, who greets people
with kisses?
Are you a Golden Retriever?
"I'm sorry about him.
He just likes the salt
on your skin."
The Biden administration
announced a new
project yesterday
that aims to, "get two million
of the most vulnerable,
older adults vaccinated
as soon as possible."
Basically, they're just
going to trick 'em.
[ Laughter ]
Acting Capitol Police Chief
Yogananda Pittman
told lawmakers yesterday
that threats against
members of Congress
have nearly doubled
over the past year,
along with a tenfold
increase in threats
from members of Congress.
The Washington Football Team
has announced
that they will replace
their cheerleading squad
with a co-ed dance team.
So, yeah, they still
don't understand
why we're mad at them.
Washington's like
a dumb boyfriend.
"Okay, I did all the dishes.
Are you happy now?"
No! You cheated on me,
you idiot!
[ Laughter ]
According to a new study,
the United States can expect
300,000 fewer births this year,
as a result of the pandemic,
which will save
thousands of lives
that would have been lost
at gender reveal parties.
Amazon is reportedly
in negotiations with the NFL
for the exclusive rights
to Thursday Night Football,
in which case, it would become
Saturday Night Football.
[ Laughter ]
And, finally,
talk show host Dr. Oz
helped save a man's life this
week at a baggage claim area
in Newark Liberty
International Airport.
Oz snapped into action
after bystanders called out,
"Help! Help!
Is anybody here
sort of...a doctor?!"
♪♪
[ Cheering, whistling,
and applause ]